estrun la parole est à monsieur yves
nicolin merci monsieur le président je
pense que ma question va permettre au
gouvernement de revenir un petit peu de
modestie et va surtout permettre au
premier ministre de répondre à une
question qui n'est pas polémique mais
qui concerne tous nos artisans français
et nous le pme monsieur prix mini sa
lutte contre les abus du détachement des
travailleurs devaient constituer une
priorité absolue de votre gouvernement
tel n'est aujourd'hui pas le cas
pourtant ces abus sont une tragédie pour
nos entreprises nos artisans nos
collectivités
un cancer pour l'emploi et la prospérité
économique
je me permets de vous lire la
proposition commerciale qui a été
envoyée cette semaine un artisan de ma
circonscription
c'est proprement hallucinant le préfet
de la région auvergne rhône-alpes en
dispose de tous les éléments notamment
de noms que je cacherai ici notre
entreprise vise la prestation de
services dans le domaine de la sélection
recrutement et près de travailleurs dans
le domaine du bâtiment maçon pâtes plats
qu'ils coffreur couvreur carreleur
électricien poseurs menuisier et cetera
chaque équipe dispose de personnes
parlant français qui sur votre direction
réaliseront vos projets tout en
demeurant nos employés travaillant en
détachement votre entreprise vous avez
tout à gagner avec notre entreprise
augmenter votre bénéfice avec un coût
horaire parmi les plus bas du marché
vous ne paierez que les heures
effectuées pas de charges sociales pas
d'assurance pas de subvention vacances
pas de subvention noël pas de tickets
repas pas de tva
notre entreprise prend en charge le
voyage de ces ouvriers allers et retours
assurances d'accidents du travail et le
courant vers la sécurité sociale et le
remplacement des ouvriers dont vous
n'êtes pas satisfait tarif madame la
ministre
16 euros ttc par employé toutes
spécialités ces euros monsieur le
premier ministre c'est deux fois moins
que le coût horaire moyen d'un salarié
du bâtiment français alors monsieur le
premier ministre
pouvez vous m'expliquer comment résoudre
le chômage si votre gouvernement laisse
faire ce type de pratiques
la parole est à madame myriam el khomri
ministre du travail de l'emploi de la
formation professionnelle du dialogue
social merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député yves nicolin
le seul point où nous pouvons nous
retrouver sur le fait qu'il faut tout
mettre en oeuvre un évidement pour
lutter contre les fraudes au détachement
comment avons-nous agit d'abord
permettez moi de vous le rappeler ici
d'abord et en remerciant ici michel
sapin la révision de la directive de
ça a été un combat européen extrêmement
important d'abord regardons sur le plan
national ce que nous avons fait avec les
loi savary du la loi macron et puis
ensuite la loi travail
nous avons considérablement données aux
services les moyens de sanctionner mais
nous n'avons pas seulement élaborer des
lois
nous les avons appliqué l'administration
du travail est passée de 500 contrôles à
plus de 1500 2000 en juin dernier
qu'est ce que nous avons fait près de
880 amendes administratives un tiers un
tiers de ces amendes sont de la
responsabilité du donneur d'ordre
c'est ce que nous ont permis justement
les modifications législatives mais je
vais plus loin
depuis janvier 2016 nous pouvons
suspendre des chantiers d'ailleurs dans
la région et le préfet de la région
rhône-alpes hoeven a suspendu encore
récemment un chantier particulièrement
important donc nous mettons les amendes
5 millions d'euros dé récoltés en moins
d'un an
881 amende mise en oeuvre trente trois
chantiers suspendu et bientôt grâce à la
loi travail nous pourrons suspendre des
chantiers s'il n'y a pas de déclarations
et détachement mais je crois qu'il est
utile aussi de rappeler ici que la
france et sert de deuxième pays
d'accueil de travailleurs détachés mais
si nous voyons voulons être tout à fait
honnête vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens
nous sommes aussi le troisième pays
d'envoi de travailleurs détachés que
demandons nous aujourd'hui nous
demandons concrètement une révision de
la directive détachement de 96 nous le
demandons et nous soutenons la
commission européenne dans ce cadre là
et j'ai vu votre collègue madame aura
cherché du ppe
allez la voir elle vous dira ce que nous
faisons nous avons rencontré de nombreux
interlocuteurs
j'ai rencontré tous mes homologues
européens et nous sommes en train
d'avancer ce dossier nous demandons la
fin des entreprises boîte aux lettres
vous madame la ministre